If there are five rows: the first, third, and fifth would be odd rows, and the
second and fourth would be even rows. But how would we generalize this, to
figure this out let's look at a couple more examples. If the total number of
rows was 6, then even rows would be 3 and odd rows would also be 3. If the
number of rows was 7, then odd rows would be 4 and even rows would still be 3.
So, it looks like the number of odd rows is something like half of the total
number of rows, but 4 isn't exactly half of 7 over 2. It would be half of 7+1
over 2. What would happen if we added 1 on to this 6 as well. Then we will get
7 over 2, which in Javaland for integers is still 3. For the even rows 6 over 2
is 3, that one works. And 7 over 2 is pretty close to 3. In Javaland that's 3.
So, if I just divide by 2 and throw away the remainders, it looks like I get
the numbers of even rows. If you don't believe me, you can try a few more
examples. So, it looks like the total number of odd rows is the total number of
rows plus 1, over 2, and then drop the decimal. Whereas the number of even rows
is just the total number of rows over 2, and we drop the decimal. There's
another way you could calculate the odd rows. You could say that the odd rows
are always the total number of rows divided by two and then you add one if the
total number of rows is odd. So, that would be the total number over 2 plus one
if 7 is odd. And if 7 is odd then 7 mod two would be one. So, total mod 2. Save
these for later. And you could also try this one.